and you know what when Donald Trump won
in 2016 it was just the presidency
meanwhile Congress was still
establishment the Supreme Court was
still establishment and even right now
even with Trump's nominees you still get
a bit of that establishment Thomas and
Leo are pretty good we're now seeing
Maga in Congress and when they say the
Republican part is not unified I'm like
good it means there's some people who
are actually representing me at least
even if it is only a small handful of
people you know when we were unified
when we passed the Patriot Act you know
when we were unified when we went to war
in Iraq you know when we were unified
when you know when when we were willing
to take you people's Liberties away
during coid you know when we were
unified when we were printing money for
extra coid spending Unity has brought
some of the worst results we need
dissent we need the opportunity for
people to make a counterargument and
then have the best ideas rise to the top